grazie partirei da da questa prima
immagine che passata che mi ritrae
ancora molto piccolo intento a disegnare
in effetti quando mi chiedevano già a
quell'età cosa avrei fatto da grande
rispondevo senza esitazione il
disegnatore sicuramente mio padre deve
averci messo lo zampino perché lui era
pittore si respirava aria artistica in
casa però devo dire che è con i primi
fumetti che ho avuto una sorta di deaver
e illuminazione leggevo tantissimo le
mie storie preferite i miei autori
preferiti
mi appassionavo alle storie ma anche ai
disegni che osservavo e cercavo di
codificare di capire quali erano i
segreti di di quelli che per me erano un
po i maestri del disegno ancora di più
di quelli che mi insegnavano a scuola
insomma cercavo di disegnare e
riprodurre le cose che vedevo gli anni
della scuola sono stati importanti in
questo senso perché io mi mettevo sempre
in fondo nell'ultima fila scarabocchiato
tutto il tempo
i professori gli insegnanti spesso mi
assecondavano in questa mia passione
vedevano che era molto appassionato e mi
lasciavano fare a patto che non
disturbasse anzi spesso mi
incoraggiavano e questo è stata una
bella palestra per me dopo la scuola
sono passati tanti anni c'è stato
servizio militare anche di yoga o sempre
in testa al disegno disegnare disegnare
fumetti m'immaginavo veramente tanti di
disegni ho avuto la fortuna di
imbattermi in un ufficiale che aveva una
certa predisposizione sensibilità per il
disegno e che i disegni che facevo mi ha
commissionato una serie di illustrazioni
per il calendario della caserma in cui
doveva disegnare dei dei cannoni da da
combattimento d'artiglieria pesante che
non erano esattamente quello che volevo
fare nella vita però insomma l'ho fatto
con tutto l'impegno possibile il
comandante fu soddisfatto del risultato
e mi commissionò prima una serie di
ritratti per
lui per la moglie e poi per tutti i
parenti in sostanza quell'anno non ho
fatto altro che disegnare dopo questa
esperienza c'è stato c'è stata
l'università l'università e mi
interessava da un lato però mi
preoccupava anche perché in quel periodo
rischiavo di aver veramente poco tempo
per dedicare quella che era la mia
passione
vedevo che gli anni erano passati tanti
anni e non avevo ancora concluso niente
e quindi ho preso un po le cose in mano
ho deciso di presentare una selezione di
lavori all'editore che che pubblicava i
miei fumetti preferiti cioè la walt
disney
qualche settimana dopo sono stato
contattato per un colloquio e sono
partito alla volta di milano dove
ricevermi c'era giovan battista carpi un
mitico disegnatore della della scuola
disneyana di cui avevo letto
praticamente tutto e conoscevo benissimo
lo stile l'incontro con questo maestro
per me è stato molto emozionante ricordo
che quella volta gli portai alcuni
disegni che lui iniziò a scrutare
attentamente senza senza dire una parola
poi si alza e se ne andò dicendomi di
aspettarlo stati lì ad aspettarlo per
molto tempo fa sol pensano più di
mezz'ora e in questo tempo ricordo che
pensai fantastica e molto pensare di
poter cominciare finalmente a disegnare
a livello professionale
poi però cercavo di moderare un po i
miei pensieri
tornando alle alla realtà pensando che
comunque forse non era ancora al tempo
forse il mio stile non era ancora
abbastanza maturo comunque torno al
maestro con in mano un plico di fogli me
lo diede e io vidi che si trattava della
prima sceneggiatura di un fumetto
ecco quello è stato il momento per me
uno dei momenti più emozionanti della
mia vita perché fino ad allora non avevo
fatto altro che sognare e disegnare
mentre sognavo e in quel momento si
concretizzava veramente il sogno di
tanti anni era la prima sceneggiatura
se ti poi che il maestro era stato via
più di mezz'ora nel tentativo di
convincere il direttore a darmi quella
storia investendo in un giovane che non
aveva un curri
non aveva un'esperienza professionale e
per me questa fu una dimostrazione
enorme di fiducia che poi a mia volta
cercare di ricambiare con tutti quei
giovani che mi si sono presentati nel
corso degli anni giovani meritevoli che
mi hanno mostrato i loro lavori ecco
questo è un po lo spartiacque dal dal
periodo in cui ero dilettante a quando
sono diventato professionista in realtà
non sono diventato professionista in
maniera automatica
io ero ancora dilettante ma dovevo
dimostrare di saper fare certe cose a
livello professionale e questo mi aiuta
un po il mio maestro che mi seguiva
aggiustava i miei disegni e poi vivendo
in aiuto anche in con la mia
sfacciataggine dell'epoca perché quando
si è così giovani non ci si fanno troppe
domande
e così dice a macinare un'infinità di
storia di segnare tantissimo a quel
punto potevo migliorare molto più
velocemente perché non c'erano i freni
della scuola o del servizio militare e
quindi lo stile evolveva molto
rapidamente
in quel periodo è stato un periodo della
mia formazione delle proprie scoprivo
nuovi autori scoprivo che c'erano nuove
modalità di disegno mi confrontavo con
con molti colleghi è stato un periodo
molto fertile e soprattutto scoprivo che
siano delle cose molto interessanti al
di fuori del panorama fumettistico fino
a quel momento io avevo come punti di
riferimento pochi autori e gli ostile
che risentiva inevitabilmente di quelle
influenze
adesso invece cercavo di di aprire un
paul ventaglio delle conoscenze e
scoprivo che che c'erano anche autori
molto interessanti al di fuori del mondo
del fumetto
ad esempio nel
nel mondo del del cinema nella pittura
nel mondo della fotografia
in questo modo da un lato mi allontanavo
un po dal fumetto per che scoprivo cose
nuove ed estremamente entusiasmanti per
me e quindi prestato un po meno
attenzione forse a quello che era la
lettura dei fumetti che era la mia
passione originaria però in qualche modo
i nuovi interessi poi ri confluivano nel
fumetto nel senso che faccio un esempio
mi interessava molto la fotografia e
quindi cercavo di fare degli scatti con
delle inquadrature particolari che poi
potessero essere rese all'interno delle
vignette di un fumetto
allo stesso modo mi appassionavo di
architettura e l'architettura anche
quella tornava nei miei fumetti nel
senso che edifici eclettici architettura
un costante potevano poi trovare spazio
nelle storie che facevo anche il cinema
chiaramente offre offre molti spunti
utili che poi possono essere tradotti in
fumetto anzi del cinema il fumetto
spesso sono complementari e si aiutano a
vicenda
insomma devo dire che in quegli anni il
mio fumetto e se si è arricchito di
delle esperienze del mio vissuto diciamo
che poi entrava in qualche modo nelle
storie anche se poi più avanti ho capito
che molte cose che ci appartengono
devono entrare un po di nascosto nelle
storie che facciamo perché quando la
citazione o il gesto autoreferenziale
troppo evidente questo poi può
disturbare chi legge o comunque poco non
essere troppo elegante ecco io penso che
un autore di fumetti come
chiunque facciamo un lavoro creativo
debba cercare di farlo con con grande
vitalità con entusiasmo sempre cercare
di evitare di cadere nella routine o
nella noia ancora peggio per quanto mi
riguarda adotta un piccolo espediente mi
piace sempre metterli alla prova con
cose nuove
così quando ho dei lavoretti anche meno
importanti di quelli che faccio
normalmente per le grandi case editrici
e gli accetto volentieri perché mi
mettono alla prova mi spingono a
spremere un po di più le meningi a
riflettere su cose nuove da un lato si
richiede uno sforzo maggiore producono
magari dei risultati inferiori perché se
non siano ancora raggiunto una
perfezione formale
dall'altro però danno grande
soddisfazione quando alla fine uno ce la
fa
insomma questo questo penso sia un
esercizio molto utile
d'altronde se se noi guardiamo quella
che la parabola creativa di molti
artisti
notiamo che inizialmente su un periodo
di di di evoluzione che porta poi a dei
livelli molto alti spesso fino al
raggiungimento di quella che come dicevo
prima è una perfezione una sorta di
perfezione formale e fin qui tutto bene
poi si rischia di cadere in quella che
la routine cioè la ripetizione di quei
modelli che si sono acquisiti con grande
fatica senza proporre di nuovi ecco il
mio consiglio che ha dato prima forse
può aiutare a sfuggire a questo rischio
ecco avete visto adesso stanno
ricominciando le immagini
avete visto dei lavori che ho fatto in
questi ultimi anni una selezione di
lavori che sono riferiti soprattutto
alle storie disney ma non solo
avete forse visto che ci sono altre
tavole che sono per il mercato francese
tavole le chiamiamo noi stile semi
realistico non così umoristico come
quelle disneyane in francia in effetti
esiste un mercato molto importante di
fumetto il fumetto è considerato quasi
alla stregua di una forma d'arte a tutti
gli effetti
i volumi a fumetti spesso vengono
relegate proposte in libreria come se
fossero dei libri di letteratura e le
tavole a fumetti spesso esposta in
grandi musei come ad esempio anche il
louvre poi avete visto alcune tavole di
che ho fatto per l'editore bonelli che
in italia è famoso soprattutto per le
serie tex e dylan dog e infine una serie
di lavori per editori minori che non
sono destinati al grande pubblico però
spesso proprio per questo motivo danno
la possibilità maggior possibilità di
movimento per gli autori perché non sono
sottoposte ai vincoli stretti delle
grandi case editrici
ecco concluderei questo mio intervento
re agganciandomi al tema del teteks di
quest'anno che è l'ex play come per come
la intendo io
come possiamo giocare col nostro
mestiere con la nostra professione il
mio maestro diceva che è importante che
abbiamo sempre in testa una cosa cioè
che noi lavoriamo per far divertire il
nostro pubblico cioè quello dei ragazzi
e dei bambini e questo penso sia una
cosa fondamentale non dobbiamo
abbandonarci al nostro personale
divertimento ma dobbiamo sempre stare
attenti a chi c'è dall'altra parte
questo ragionamento può essere anche
capovolto sia un autore deve divertirsi
in prima persona per poter far divertire
chi usufruisce del del suo lavoro
altrimenti in autore annoiato
sicuramente non trasmetterà gioia
divertimento in chi legge
ecco quindi penso che la soluzione
ideale sia quella di rimanere sospesi in
bilico su questo crinale in cui
convivono gioco divertimento e
professionalità io non so se ci sono
riuscito qualche volta sì qualche volta
no però devo dire che
quando quando qualche lettore è venuto a
dirmi che si era molto divertito a
leggere la mia storia e io sapevo che
nel farla mi ero divertito ecco questo è
stato forse il momento di più grande
soddisfazione grazie